With this century and the emergence of
new technologies, the ruling party lost
the ability to control the flow of
information. I
built my first computer in 1994.
My husband I remember that he baptized all
those pieces spread out on the table
as Frankenstein. Immediately
after having the technology came the
desire to communicate, express and
spread content
that when I opened my blog it was like a
process of exorcism inside me
there was a great need to
tell and narrate and above all in a way that I
had not seen or played I had seen
Cuban ra since  the official press, in
very ideological and very political terms,
voices were missing from the people. On the other
hand, there was a great campaign of
official demonization against the Internet,
the Cuban ruling party was already
announcing that there was something perverse and
built by imperialism and
capitalism
in May 2014 together  a group of
colleagues decided to found a
digital newspaper the first newspaper that was  he has
done it independently from within
cuba he created a podcast it is a very
simple format very simple but incredibly
and it reaches many people I have had
very nice testimonies from
very very old Cuban peasants in the middle of the
field who listen to me and tell me that
they cannot  read because their eyes
won't allow them because they're blind
because they can't they don't have a laptop
but they listen to me 14 y medio is a
digital site blocked on Cuban servers
but watch out cuba is the country of
tricks they come through next
anonymous they come to  through
fp n services they arrive through offline copies
of our site
this small device that has
changed the lives of us Cubans so much that it
is the flash memory or usb memory a
small flash memory fits
anywhere and can carry a lot of
information  then the square of the
revolution the Cuban ruling party
cannot place a policeman on every corner
to see who has a flash memory and
who  n I
am not absolutely protected by the people
who follow me on twitter it is a dynamic
that is a bit difficult to understand
when you live in the free world and
social networks seem more like a place
for debate, controversy and confrontation
but when you live in  a society under
a totalitarian regime in a society under
surveillance in a society controlled
until every second of your life the
social networks become a
protective visibility in
November 2009 and that is that I was going to
publicly participate in a call that
the young artists had made
against censorship that before leaving a friend
told me we are going to write an sms a
text message we are going to leave it in the
outbox just in case they
stop us report that we are detained
on the way to her we were
kidnapped by a group of
linked men  to the political police or
state security when they
intercepted us I had enough seconds
before they m  and they
forced their way into a car or a vehicle to
send by text message
that tweet that said we have been
detained later inside the car it was
a scene of great violence there were two
men one of whom was on top of me with his
knee on my chest  they hit me they
talked about my hair the driver received
a call I look back and tell
the men who were beating
me let them already know and half
had traveled to the virtual world had
traveled to the internet and that was
still protecting me in the middle of the  repressive act
the information is now entering through
all the pores of the system and that brings
the rupture of the official narrative the
questioning of how the
executive works the denunciations of corruption
the images of the injustices and all
that is a very very aggressive cocktail for
the ruling party
[Music]